-Our next guest is the legendary
and award-winning author
of more than 50 books,
including "The Blind Assassin,"
"The Handmaid's Tale,"
and "The Testaments."
Her latest, "Old Babes
in the Wood," is on sale today.
Please welcome back to the show
the great Margaret Atwood.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Margaret.
-Well, remember
what was happening
when we last saw each other?
We were about to have COVID.
-We were about to have COVID.
It was 2019.
It was right -- It felt like
the very eve of it.
-It was, yeah.
And what's happened
in the interval?
No time at all has passed.
You look just the same.
-Thank you very much.
I think you look
maybe even younger.
I think you've done
extremely well for yourself.
I do want to talk -- because
the last time you were here,
we were discussing your
wonderful book "The Testaments,"
and we didn't discuss a thing
that I knew to be true,
that you were going through
an incredibly tough loss.
It was a time of grieving
for you.
And it does seem like this book
is maybe a means of addressing
the loss that you went through.
-Yes, well, I walked off the
plane right after Graeme died,
and I walked right on to
your show in a state of shock.
-And this was your partner --
-I can't remember
anything I said to you.
-Well, it speaks to --
-Except I read your hand.
-You did.
You gave me a palm reading.
And I remember you said,
"I think COVID's coming,"
and I'm like, "I don't even know
what that is."
-I did not say that.
-You did not say that.
-[ Laughs ]
-And this was your partner
of over 50 years.
-Yes.
-And did writing this book --
Was that a catharsis for you?
-Well, I'd written
these two characters,
Nell and Tig, before.
They're in an earlier book
of stories.
But in the earlier book,
they're both still alive.
So in some of these stories,
they're both still alive,
and in some of these stories,
one of them is not.
So I have to explain to younger
people, at my age --
which is 32 --
[ Laughter ]
At my age, you can expect
people to die.
It happens.
And it's different
from a younger person dying,
and it's really different
from a child dying.
So those are tragedies.
And this, after the age of 80
or so, is the circle of life.
-Does that make it easier
to process, though?
-No, it doesn't.
-I would imagine it can't be,
right?
-It doesn't,
but on the other hand,
Graeme was a very wise person.
He had had his diagnosis
in 2012.
He had a particular kind
of vascular dementia
that causes you to die
of a cerebral hemorrhage,
which is what he did.
His family had a habit of dying
in London, England,
and so did he.
-Alright, well...
You wouldn't think that would
be genetic, but there you go.
-It's not genetic.
I think it's sort of, you know,
quasi-intentional.
-There you go.
-I don't know.
-Very fitting because
this book is very beautiful
and it does touch on grief and
loss, but it's also very funny.
There's an opening story
about this couple
going to a first-aid class,
and --
-It's all true.
-Is it all true?
So you went
to a first-aid class.
-We absolutely had to go to one,
and everybody there was
considerably younger than us.
So our thing was, you know what?
You find the person unconscious
on the sidewalk.
One person calls 911.
The other one
does the mouth-to-mouth,
and then the first one
has to help the second one
up off the floor.
But, you know, if there's
a red plastic torso
with a tipped-back head in
trouble, I'll be there for them.
[ Laughter ]
-Plastic, ideally plastic.
Yeah.
You know, "Handmaid's Tale"
has been coming up again.
Obviously, you know, it's a book
that's back in the public eye.
But it also is a book that's
showing up on banned book lists.
I mean,
this is something that --
another thing
that you can't believe
one's guard can be put down on
that they would ever ban books
again, but of course they are.
You took it in your own hands
when you heard that there was
maybe some book banning.
Explain to us exactly
what you're doing here.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
This was
the unburnable book project.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
So that is actually
an unburnable book,
and we did a little video of it.
It actually took them
about five tries
to make one that wouldn't burn,
but they did manage it.
And that is
a real flamethrower.
-Did you take a class for that,
Margaret?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-You seem very confident
with it, I will say.
-Yes.
They were a little worried.
And after we had done the shoot,
they did take it away from me
quite quickly.
-Well, it certainly
would be very ironic
if it's like, "Good news,
the book didn't burn.
Bad news...
we lost Margaret."
-No, it wouldn't have been me
that they lost.
It would have been --
-That's true.
You did know well enough
to point it out.
-None of my enemies
were in the room.
-Well, that's alright.
Just for insurance reasons,
they couldn't take that risk.
You know, obviously,
over 50 books.
You're incredibly well-known,
but I do enjoy hearing stories
like this
because, you know,
it reminds us all to be humble.
Is it true that you had
a book signing once
where no one showed up?
-Oh, it was so humiliating.
Yeah, so it was in a mall in
Winnipeg on a Tuesday afternoon.
-Okay.
-Nobody was in the mall,
and certainly nobody
was in the bookstore.
There I sat with my little book,
my little table,
and outside in the mall hallway,
as it were,
I saw this guy coming -- plunk,
plunk, plunk, plunk, plunk.
And I thought,
"Here comes my customer."
He opens the door.
He comes up to me.
Plunk, plunk,
plunk, plunk, plunk.
And he says,
"Where's the Scotch tape?"
[ Laughter ]
And I say...
"I think it's at the back."
He says, "Thanks."
That was it.
-That was it?
That was the entirety of it?
-That was it.
-Well, I mean, they say
there's a rule in publishing.
Never do a book signing in
a Winnipeg mall on a Tuesday.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, my first book signing
was even better -- or worse --
because it was in the men's
sock and underwear department
of the Hudson's Bay Company,
a department store,
in Edmonton, Alberta, in 1969.
Why was it there?
I don't know.
It was near an escalator.
I think the publicist, whose
first week on the job it was,
thought, "Escalator,
people will go up and down.
They'll see Margaret sitting
amongst the jockey shorts
with her book called
'The Edible Woman'
and they will think, 'I would
like to buy one of those.'"
That didn't happen.
-Then you have guys
who'd come home
and they'd be like,
"Did you get socks?"
It's like, "I totally forgot.
I got this signed book."
-What really happened
was that I --
It's a lot of clomping
in these stories.
These ones had galoshes on,
okay?
So galoshes, galoshes, galoshes.
Uhh.
They ran away very fast.
I could hear their galoshes.
-Well, now I believe you hear
everyone running to you,
running to your work.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It's such a delight
to have you back.
That's Margaret Atwood,
everybody.
"Old Babes in the Wood"
is available now
wherever you buy your books.
But please support local
and independent bookstores
and malls in Winnipeg.
We'll be right back.